le silence dans les rues se fait
toujours entendre au mois d'avril
mais si les corps des yvelinois sont
confinés leurs esprits restent ouverts
l'astronaute français jean françois
clervoy habitué au confinement lors de
ses voyages dans l'espace ne dit pas le
contraire dans ces conseils donnés pour
vivre cette épreuve c'est très important
d'être de s'astreindre à te donner à la
planning
si on attend que quelqu'un nous dise
quoi faire on peut facilement se
retrouver à devenir wazi pc c'est
malsain avec les esprits les choeurs
sont aussi tournés vers les autres des
élans de solidarité spontanée émergent
ce jeune runner a fait un marathon dans
son jardin une performance dans le cadre
d'un mécénat autour de la chirurgie
cardiaque des actions pour soutenir les
soignants ce garagiste propose des prix
réduits pour réparer les véhicules des
soignants le chef étoilé de la table du
11 jean baptiste lavergne mourad zanni à
cuisiner pour le personnel hospitalier
une solidarité pouvant aller au bout de
la vie le docteur jacques fribourg
médecin urgentiste retraités de
l'hôpital privé de l'ouest parisien de
trappes est décédée à cause du coc vite
19 il était sorti de sa retraite pour
aider le personnel soignant de
l'établissement à affronter la crise
sanitaire
chaque ccc symbole pour nous il était
dans son hôpital dans son établissement
depuis un mois et s'est battu comme un
diable pour pour survivre et il décède
chez nous c'est un sentiment beaucoup de
tristesse s'est énormément tristesse
puis l'espoir vient le 13 avril 2020 de
l'elysée le confinement le plus strict
doit encore se poursuivre jusqu'au lundi
11 mai
le déconfinement sera progressif par
territoire tous les commerces dits non
essentiels pourront rouvrir
tout comme les crèches et les écoles
maternelles et primaires
et quand le 11 mai est arrivée alors moi
je veux pas du tout sorti et c'est un
petit peu bizarre ça vous regarde tous
là un peu peur mais un préfet sortir
j'ai rendez vous chez le coiffeur là
dans dix minutes
donc voila c'était la première la
première chose à faire ce matin les
coiffeurs ont fait le plein les golfeurs
ont pu revenir sur les greens et les
magasins des centres commerciaux ont
relevé leurs rideaux avec une
organisation particulière pour respecter
les règles sanitaires
puis le 2 juin c'est au tour des
enseignements qui ont repris dans les
collèges et les lycées
les restaurateurs ont pu remettre les
couverts et reprendre du service
le serveur ont démasqué pourrait servir
les clients avec les marées vont pas
avoir les masques à table est attendu
dans l'établissement ils émettront des
masques pour aller aux toilettes on va
éviter qu'ils viennent payer à la caisse
à table le déconfinement concerne aussi
les élus politiques ils ont pu de
nouveau se réunir en assemblée
c'est le cas de l'établissement public
interdépartemental yvin hauts-de-seine
qui a pu les lire georges siffredi à la
présidence de l'organisation
suite à la disparition de patrick
devedjian
après un premier tour au mois de mars le
second tour des élections municipales de
2020 a été organisée le 28 juin
suite à ce scrutin quatre nouveaux
maires ont été élus à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines aux
clayes-sous-bois philippe guiguen
devient le nouvel édile de la commune à
villepreux le candidat modem jean
baptiste à mo'nique a remporté les
suffrages les trappistes ont voté
majoritairement pour le candidat de la
gauche aly rabais enfin la verrière a
basculé à droite avec la victoire de
nicolas dainville une commune sous
pavillon communiste depuis 1977